okay
now we're going to talk about more
adventurous methods
and more modern as well
and so piecewise polynomials
generalize the idea of piecewise
constants so instead of having a single
polynomial in x over its whole domain
you can use different polynomials in
each region instead of different
constants for different polynomials
so this next figure
shows a piecewise polynomial in two
regions
so here in the top left panel there's a
piecewise polynomial it's a cubic
polynomial there's the not at 50
and it's it's a cubic to the left and a
cubic to the right they're two different
cubic polynomials and they just fit to
the data
this one's fit to the data on the left
this one's fit to the data on the right
what do you think of that rob
uh there's a break in the middle it's
not just pretty ugly isn't it
it's pretty ugly so
but that is a piecewise cubic polynomial
but the breaks ugly so it's better to
add constraints to the polynomials for
example continuity
so in this top right panel we've got a
cubic polynomial in the left a cubic in
the right
but we forced it
to be continuous at the knot
so that looks much better already this
is already starting to look like the
function we got from the polynomial the
global polynomial but
we can actually see this little kink in
the middle here
and in this case it's not too egregious
but in some situations
continuity is not enough
so
you can enforce
continuity in
on on the derivatives as well
so this function here this red one is
actually called a cubic spline
and what it is is it's a cubic
polynomial in the left and the right
it's continuous at the knot
the first con first derivatives
continuous
at the knot and the second derivatives
continuous at the knot
so there's three constraints
and that's called a spline
now we couldn't make the third
derivative continuous because then it
would just be a global cubic polynomial
so we've made as enough continuity as we
can still allowing some separate
separate functions in
a
cubic in each region
that's called a cubic spline
while we on it you we we could have
linear polynomials and here's a linear
spline so it's or piecewise linear
function
it's it's linear in in the left and the
right
and it's forced to be continuous at the
knot so
the amount of continuity you can enforce
is one the order of continuity is one
less than the degree of the polynomial
and so here we can only enforce degree
zero continuity whereas here we're
forcing degree two
while it's a third degree polynomial so
maybe just sort of be clear where we've
thought our thoughts evolved right we
started off with a global polynomial and
we didn't like that because it was
global right so because the fit at one
end would be affected by points at the
other end so then we moved to something
which more local piecewise constants and
they were local except they're not very
smooth so now you want something that's
both smooth and local so that on the top
left panel we have something which is
local
it's smooth in each panel but it's not
smooth at the knots so now we sort of
move towards a compromise where it's
it's it's it's local but it's also
smooth through the throughout the whole
range
thanks thanks
um
and as i said splines have the maximum
amount of continuity
um by the way it's believed that a cubic
spline
the discontinuity which exists in the
third derivative is not detectable by
the human eye and it certainly seems
right for my eyes
but i wouldn't trust my eyes
okay so let's go into a bit more detail
about these splines so we'll first do
linear splines and then we'll do cubic
splines
so
in the linear spline with knots at psi k
k equals one to capital k so you can put
down we've had one not in these pictures
but you can put down multiple knots
is the definition is the piecewise
linear polynomial continuous at each
knot
and
just like with the in the previous cases
with the global polynomials in the and
the and the
the constant function piecewise constant
functions
you can represent this as a we call it a
linear expansion in basis functions
so transformations of the variables
okay in this case what you have is you
have the variable itself so one of these
basis functions is just the variable
itself
and then you have a collection of these
truncated functions
basis functions they call truncated
power functions but this one's to power
one
and
it's
here it is
it's x i minus c k positive part
and what that means is described below
here
is it's equal to x i minus c k
if
x is bigger than c k
and it's zero otherwise so it's not
allowed to go negative
and so you make one of these functions
at each of the knots
and
these transformations and you throw them
in as additional variables
so to see how this works let's look at a
figure
so the blue curve is a is a just a
global linear function
yes
we've only got one not here so here's
one of these basis functions
see
it starts off at zero at the knot and
then it goes up linearly
so this is is x minus 0.6 positive part
below 0.6 it's zero
so now when you fit a linear model with
with a global linear function plus one
of these in
and each of them gets a coefficient
what you get is you get a function
that's allowed to change its slope at
the knot
so if you add in some mix of this to a
linear function it'll
change the slope of this point and so
here we see it over here
okay
and because this starts off at zero it
makes sure it's continuous here
very handy and you can make a bunch of
these functions for however many knots
you've got
cubic splines
very similar idea so first of all the
definition the cubic spline with knots
at c k k going from 1 to capital k
is a piecewise cubic polynomial with
continuous derivatives up to order 2 at
each knot so that's the definition of a
cubic spline
again you can represent this as a basis
expansion in the original variables
in this case
you need
x1 x1 sorry x x squared and x cubed
so the basis for cubic polynomials of
course the constant's always in the
model
okay
and then you have similar
truncated power functions but now
they're raised to the power three
one at each knot
where this guy is defined to be x i
minus c k
cubed if x i is bigger than c k and 0
otherwise
but the idea's the same
and here's the picture so now here's the
little basis function this truncated
power basis function and it's a little
cubic
polynomial that's zero at at the knot
in this figure over here here's the
global cubic polynomial the blue one
and here's
added in some little
a linear combination of this orange guy
and that'll change the cubic part of the
function in this region
and
a bit of a detail this spaces function
if you if you check it out for yourself
you'll find out that it's
it's zero at the knot it's also got zero
first derivative and zero second
derivative of the knot
so when you add it in here you don't
change the derivative those derivatives
of the function and so it has the
required continuity of a cubic spline
so really handy representation
okay so cubic splines
are used all over the place and and
you'll see we even got fancier versions
one fancier version is is very handy and
it's the one i tend to use all the time
it's called a natural cubic spline
if you have the choice of a cubic spline
and a natural cubic spline which one
would you use right
natural like this
like that's a it's a good choice of
names
what a natural cubic spline is it's a
cubic spline where you've added two
extra constraints at the boundaries and
the constraints make the function
extrapolate linearly beyond the boundary
knots
and what that means is that
the ends of the the function aren't just
left unconstrained we saw for a global
cubic polynomial that the tail could wag
quite a lot we're not going to let that
happen here because we're going to make
the function go off linearly beyond the
range of the data
okay
and so what that does is
it adds four constraints two on each end
and that frees up four parameters so
for the for the same number of degrees
of freedom or parameters in your model
you can you can
you can put extra knots in the middle
and get more flexibility
so in this figure we've got a cubic
spline and a and a natural cubic spline
now you don't in the fitted function you
don't see much difference
you'll see the cubic splines a bit more
wiggly at this end over here
the standard errors you see are much
wider
in places for the cubic spline
especially at the boundary which is
where the ac the effect of the natural
spline is is taking place and the
standard areas for the natural spine are
better there
i'm actually working on something called
organic cube explains which will be even
better
i can't give you details yet you call me
but that one should catch on i think
especially here in california
very good
okay fitting splines in r is easy
there's a function bs
which takes a variable x and has some
arguments you can give it the knots for
example
and
or there's other ways of specifying the
flexibility and it'll just do the work
you you put that in a formula and you
can put one of those for what whichever
function you want to be a non-linear and
it'll just do the work for you did you
think of the name of that function
i can see you don't like the name no
don't get rude rob
and that's for cubic splines and for
natural splines
ns
and here we see a function of age here's
a natural cubic spline you can see it's
got three knots interior knots
um and as a function of age and gives
you a very nice fit standard errors are
included
and here it's done for for the logistic
regression at the same time okay and for
this you need to use the package splines
okay
so there's some details and one is not
placement
as in knot placement
so one strategy is to decide on the
total number of knots say capital k
and then
and then given that that number just to
place the knots at appropriate quantiles
of the observed variable x
okay so just to spread them out sort of
uniformly having roughly the same amount
of data in each of the regions to find
created by the knots
and when you do that that results in a
certain number of parameters so
a cubic spline with k naughts turns out
it's got k plus four parameters or we
call them degrees of freedom
um and as i mentioned before
if you use a natural spline with k knots
it only has k degrees of freedom because
you get back two degrees of freedom for
the two constraints on each of the
boundaries
so in this figure over here we've gone a
little extreme
we've
we show a comparison
of a degree 14 polynomial and a natural
cubic spline
and that will the natural cubic spline
will have
um
we'll will have
also 14 knots
turns out there's 15 degrees of freedom
because the constant we we're not
counting the constants in in these
specifications over here
and and so here we see them
the net at the natural cubic spline is
is much smoother than the very wiggly
polynomial okay
and you can see the tail of this
polynomial going crazy
so generally i think take away messages
although polynomials are easy to think
of splines are much better behaved and
more local and so they're the way to go
and since they're so easy to work with